screen for Theta between 0 and pi and F between 0 and 2 pi notice that we have precisely the
same degeneracy as before which is that fi is irrelevant when Theta is either zero or pi and this time we can actually
see that more clearly because the S of theta is is zero in those two cases and otherwise it isn't it's worth pointing
out that in this formula we have Theta appearing as an argument to the sign and cosine functions rather than Theta over 2 as in the original Quantum State
Vector version and that's because we use those trigonometric identities the first three of which are basically
rearrangements of the so-called double angle formulas so the angle effectively gets doubled and now we're finally ready to
talk about the block sphere itself let's focus on the three coefficients of the non-identity poly
matrices in the numerator of the expression of our density Matrix so we're ignoring the two in the
denominator we're also ignoring the identity Matrix because the coefficient on that one never changes that happens because that
coefficient is determined by the trace of whatever Matrix we're expressing and density matrices always have Trace equal
to one now imagine that we have three axes labeled x y and z oriented according to
the so-called right- hand rule and consider the point whose coordinates match with the three coefficients and just to be clear this
is ordinary three-dimensional space we're talking about where the coordinates are always real numbers the
x coordinate corresponds to the coefficient of the sigma X poly Matrix in the numerator of our expression which is always a real number because density
matrices are herian and likewise for Y and Z what we find is that this point that
we obtain is always on the unit sphere or in other words the sphere having radius equal to
one and in particular it's the point we get if we start at the point where the positive z- axis intersects the sphere
which we can think about as the North Pole rotate down towards the positive x-axis by an angle of theta and then
rotate towards the positive y- AIS or in other words East by an angle of fi in this context the angle Theta is
called the polar angle which is easy to remember because it starts at the pole and F is called the azimuthal
angle and together these two angles represent spherical coordinates for the points on the unit sphere and if you
wanted to you could also allow the radius to vary to represent arbitrary points in threedimensional space but here we're focusing on points on the
unit sphere where the radius is equal to one you can also think about Theta as representing latitude except that we go
from 0 to 180° from the North Pole to the south pole rather than plus orus 90° from the equator and F represents
longitude where we basically Define the prime meridian to be the Meridian that intersects the positive
xaxis if you're like me by the way and you have trouble keeping straight which one is latitude and which one is longitude it may be helpful to remember
that longitude corresponds to the interval that's longer 2 pi as opposed to
Pi anyway the point we obtain on the unit sphere from our Cubit State Vector s by thinking about coordinates in this
way is the block sphere representation of the quantum State corresponding to SAI and when we think about the entire
three-dimensional unit sphere in this way we obtain the block sphere geometrically it's just a unit
sphere in ordinary three-dimensional space but in fact that is the geometry of Cubit
States there's a perfect one toone correspondence here every pure state of a cubit corresponds to a unique point on
the sphere and every point on the sphere represents a unique Cubit State up to a global phase when we're working with
Quantum State vectors this correspondence does go by other names by the way it's also sometimes called the poar a sphere for
instance but in the context of quantum information it's generally referred to as the block sphere notice that we can now see the
degeneracy in the angle fi pretty clearly because longitude has no meaning at the North and South Poles but aside
from the poles every point on the Earth has unique coordinates in terms of latitude and longitude and the same thing is happening here so that is how
the block sphere Works in general now let's take a look at a few specific examples of Cubit States and
where they lie on the Block sphere let's start with the standard basis these are the points we obtain
when the polar angle Theta is zero for the zero State and Pi for the one state these are the two cases where the
asmuth angle fi is irrelevant as I've already discussed we can also Express the corresponding density matrices as linear
combinations of poly matrices in either way we conclude that these two states correspond to the North Pole and to the
South Pole of the block sphere the zero state is on the top and the one state is on the
bottom next let's find the plus and minus states on the Block sphere again we can either think about
Quantum State vectors or or density matrices for Quantum State vectors this time the polar angle Theta has to be Pi
/ 2 in order to get the Zero Entry to be 1/ < tk2 the azimuthal angle F has to be zero
for the plus State because the one entry is positive for the plus State and it has to be Pi or 180° for the minus State
because that one is negative in that case so these two points lie on the
equator of the block sphere the plus state is where the positive x-axis intersects the sphere and the minor state is on the opposite side where the
negative x-axis intersects the sphere equivalently we can also see from the polymatrix expressions for the
corresponding density matrices that the Y and Z coordinates are both zero whereas the x coordinates are positive and negative
1 another example is the plus I minus I basis which is similar to the plus minus basis except that we also multiply the
one entry by I the imaginary unit we saw the plus I State earlier in the lesson and the minus I state is defined
in an analogous way the polar angle Theta is the same as it was for the plus and minus States pi/
2 and this time we need to choose the athal angle F so that we get I and negative I rather than 1 and negative 1
and Pi / 2 and 3 Pi / 2 are the right choices to make that happen once again we can also look at
the density Matrix descriptions of these states and things are pretty similar to the previous two examples except that this time is the poly y Matrix in place
of Z or X so on the Block sphere these two states are located where the y- AIS
intersects the sphere and if we clean things up a bit we can see more clearly how the Six States we just discussed
relate to one another for just one more example or really a class of examples consider the
Cubit State vectors that came up earlier and in Lesson Four where the Zero Entry is cosine of alpha for some real number Alpha and the one